there are over 800 episodes in the star
trek franchise and while most of those
are filled with amazing adventures a few
stories fail completely and
problematically keep watching to learn
the times that star trek went too far
when star trek picard was first
announced in 2019 patrick stewart warned
fans during a university visit that it
might not be the continuation of star
trek the next generation they expected
and shocked they were when star trek
voyager fan favorite character icheb the
escaped borg child from the delta
quadrant who returned home with the ship
to the federation was unceremoniously
killed off in the opening moments of
stardust city rag not only did many fans
see it as a slap in the face to kill off
the beloved character but how they did
it went too far the episode opens with a
villainous doctor brutally torturing
icheb who's now a starfleet lieutenant
and ripping out his eye in a gory and
graphic scene the irony is that she is
seeking his cortical node which icheb
gave to seven when her life was in
danger in the voyager episode
imperfection it's a nice bit of
continuity and ichib's death does help
serve to motivate seven's character
appropriately that said the blood-soaked
torture scene with ichab's visceral
screams seemed woefully out of place and
unnecessarily graphic even for the more
adult skewing picard
star trek the motion picture was the
first live-action glimpse at kirk spock
mccoy and the enterprise that audiences
had gotten in a decade it ushered in a
new era of family-friendly movies and
television shows which would run
uninterrupted for more than 25 years but
one moment in that seminal film stands
as darker and more horrifying than
anything else seen in the franchise with
the enterprise undergoing its refit two
officers are beamed up to the ship
but the transporter malfunctions and
deforms the pair into a terrifying mass
of half-transported flesh
the cries of agony from the victims can
be heard echoing through the transporter
room
thankfully the audience is spared a
graphic look at the results as they are
beamed immediately back to earth after
which the transporter chief tells kirk
enterprise
what we got back didn't live long
fortunately
it's a shocking scene that feels out of
place in what is otherwise a
family-friendly star trek movie
in an episode that dealt with issues of
identity vulcan security chief tuvak is
caught in a transporter accident with
the ship's chef nelix
unlike the horrific accident in the
motion picture the pair aren't deformed
but merged into one new sentient being
tuvix
logical like tuvak and carefree like
nelix he's an entirely new person he's a
compelling character in his own right
who under other circumstances might have
been a welcome full-time addition to the
show
but the doctor discovers a way to
reverse the accident and bring back
tubac and nelix the only problem is that
it would mean essentially killing tuvix
the new being refuses the procedure on
the grounds that he's his own person now
and entitled to exist
even the doctor says it's a violation of
his medical ethics to perform the
procedure leaving captain janeway to do
it a heartbreaking moment occurs on the
bridge when tuvix begs someone anyone to
stand up and stop the captain from
killing him it's a powerful moment
because none of the crew respond to his
pleas instead choosing to respect their
captain's decision
code of honor has been spoken about
endlessly and those involved with the
early first season episode of star trek
the next generation have mentioned their
regret and embarrassment over it many
times throughout the years but code of
honor is simply too far over the line of
decency to ignore and it's a lot more
than just one scene moment or character
that goes too far the entire episode is
packed with racism and misogyny with the
backward alien culture portrayed by all
black actors with heavy accents fighting
to the death in primitive ritual combat
over a white woman
and there's seemingly no lesson here no
moral dilemma or ethical problem that
justifies what we see
there was no attempt to use racial
stereotypes to tell the audience about
the awful truth of intolerance either
exposing that intolerance might have
mitigated the uncomfortable nature of
the portrayal what's worse it's just a
poorly written poorly acted and
all-around bad episode making it an easy
skip on any series rewatch
on star trek enterprise captain archer
was a kirklike leader who would command
an away mission and was unafraid to buck
protocol but like kirk he was also a
morally upstanding captain he always
tried to do the right thing help those
in need and see the best in every
situation no matter how dire it may have
looked that's why his dramatic shift
during the third season's zindy war
story arc was so striking and crossed
the line for many fans when a mysterious
alien race commits an unprovoked attack
on earth killing millions the enterprise
is dispatched to find the zindy during
the story archer goes from a man who
always does the right thing to a violent
captain willing to break every starfleet
rule in service of revenge
they try to justify his actions by
saying that the cindy are intent on
wiping out all of humanity but on an
episode by episode basis it often
doesn't add up produced in a post-9 11
world archer's turn mirrored many
real-life shifts in public thinking at
the time but for star trek known for its
unyielding optimism it went too far
there were other options than corrupting
one of starfleet's greatest captains
the final episode of the original series
turnabout intruder sank as low as it
could go into the waters of misogyny
captain kirk encounters his ex-lover
janice lester and there are problems
right away when she says your world of
starship captains doesn't admit women
fans have sometimes interpreted this as
starfleet not allowing women to be
captains and they may be right she
implies that it's why she has never been
able to achieve a command position she
uses a strange device to swap bodies
with kirk forcing her former lover to
experience the abuse and marginalization
that she has endured throughout the
story lester is kirk who's intent on
killing the crew attempts to rule the
enterprise with a conniving petty fist
she turns the tough skilled respected
captain kirk into a petulant and whiny
brat this sends the message that women
are incompetent and incapable of
leadership while men alone are strong
proficient and worthy of command no one
has ever figured out if this was
roddenberry's own bias or simply a bad
script gone wrong but it goes way way
too far
if you thought turnabout intruder was
bad the star trek deep space nine
episode profit in lace is even worse
rather than use the sexist state of
ferengi culture to provide commentary on
sexism in the real world profit and lace
plays on the worst gender stereotypes it
makes a mockery not just of women but of
the lgbtq community and trans people
specifically the episode uses a gender
swap as a plot device for quark to get
what he wants and even though the
writers try to have him learn a lesson
about how to treat women it's ruined by
the implication that it's only the
residual results of his transition while
it is noble that the show tried to say
something about women's rights on
ferengar at least it's still the men who
get the job done and though some have
defended it in recent years it's an
episode that should never have made it
off the drawing board for many reasons
it's a farcical episode that plays on
stereotypes and we're comfortable saying
it will never make anyone's top star
trek episode list
we've seen cisco taking morally grey
actions in the past but in those
instances his decisions are usually
justified with grave consequences or by
millions of lives being on the line a
guilty conscience is a small price to
pay
for the safety of the alpha quadrant
there's little such justification for
his actions in for the uniform cisco's
reasons for going too far are almost
entirely motivated by a personal
vendetta it all starts in the episode
for the cause when the longtime
starfleet security chief is revealed as
a maki terrorist captain cisco takes
this betrayal hard not just because
eddington defected from starfleet but
because he never suspected eddington's
duplicity when we get to for the uniform
cisco is on the hunt for eddington
making it very clear that this is
personal the former security chief
didn't just betray starfleet he betrayed
cisco the captain can't handle the fact
that eddington beat him in their first
encounter
now with eddington threatening to poison
an entire cardassian planet cisco goes
way too far to catch his prey he
destroys the ecosystem of an entire maki
world to get eddington to surrender
nearly wiping out an entire population
of the planet though the maquis would be
able to escape and find a new home his
actions betrayed every starfleet ideal
it could have resulted in a massive
death toll if it went wrong and in
reality it should have seen him at least
court-martialed for his actions
even star trek the next generation
wasn't immune to misogyny too often the
women of the enterprise were given weak
episodes nowhere was this more evident
than with counselor troy who is often
either shown as bratty obsessed with
food or being distracted by a romantic
conquest she was the victim of assault
or bodily violation on more than one
occasion but it reached its worst moment
in star trek nemesis in the film troy
serves little purpose other than to
become the target of the villain's
sexual aggression shinzon uses the help
of a powerful riemann servant to invade
troy's mind and engage in telepathic
sexual assault it's an element that has
no place in the film we already
understand how vile shinzon is and it
seems solely motivated by the producer's
desire for a sex scene and perhaps to
give troy something to do making troy a
victim once again isn't the meaty star
trek character arc they think it is
the next generation marked the
long-awaited return of star trek to
living rooms and it was aimed at the
same family audience as the original the
new series was once again a bright
colorful optimistic look at the future
with the crew who all got along fighting
for peace and equality throughout the
galaxy but the first season episode
conspiracy gave audiences a darker story
than they might have expected a story
that in hindsight would probably have
been better suited to deep space nine in
an unsettling opening picard is warned
of a dire threat he is told that
something is wrong at starfleet and it
goes all the way to the top the
conspiracy comes to the enterprise when
a high-ranking admiral tries to kill
commander riker and implant him with an
alien bug that will control his mind in
the climax the leader of the
interstellar invasion commander remick
is revealed as the mastermind
picard and his first officer confront
him at starfleet headquarters fully
revealed they proceed to blow his head
apart with phaser fire and eviscerate
his upper torso in a graphic scene that
likely horrified family audiences
watching in 1987.
the star trek enterprise episode
similitude sees tucker terminally
wounded along with the clone created to
help restore him to life while the clone
gets accustomed to living on the ship he
bonds with the crew in some of the most
beautiful moments of the series
it's also the episode where tapal learns
that tripp is in love with her taking
their ongoing relationship story to the
next level the problem however is that
the clone of tucker is created for the
sole purpose of using his organs to save
the original this unique form of cloning
results in a being whose lifespan is
just two weeks it's an ethical problem
discussed only briefly and they once
again used the zindy war to justify
their creation of the clone knowing it
will die in days the heartbreaking life
and death of the sim clone are what make
the episode great however we can't help
but feel that bringing a life into being
simply to harvest its organs was a bit
too dark and too far it could have been
more interesting if the clone brought
about a discussion over the implications
of genetic cloning instead it seems like
a cheap manipulative plot device to pull
at the audience's heartstrings
star trek rarely shied away from
addressing sensitive and controversial
subjects the voyager episode retrospect
is no exception which sees seven
assaulted in an obvious rape allegory
the attack occurs when a merchant works
with seven on the installation of a
weapon system aboard voyager during
their time together he expresses
interest in the nanoprobe technology
that powers her borg implants and is
told that they are not for sale but
after seven attacks the visitor she
finds herself in sickbay where she has
an acute panic attack the doctor helps
her recover repressed memories of kovin
forcibly extracting the nanoprobes
against her will while there are many
moments in retrospect that speak to the
real traumas faced by victims of sex
crimes star trek voyager goes too far
with the premise they turn what could
have been a powerful episode about
sexual assault and how allegations are
too often ignored into a story about the
wrongfully accused and how recovered
memories can spark false allegations
retrospect chose not to focus on an
important issue and found itself sending
all the wrong messages
if you or someone you know has been the
victim of sexual assault you can report
it by calling the national sexual
assault hotline at 1-800-656-4673
[Music]